the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu now what I want to do now is
basically summarized all the the themes
of eat basically summarized the theme of
each of the sessions that we've had
partly as a way of reminding you of all
the things we did and jog and also
jogging your memory or any questions
that you might have about that and then
it'll be your chance to ask questions so
I'm going to do it so I'll think aloud
here mmm I'll do it in a way that I can
leave them up the whole time so let me
do it here I'll do it on these two guys
yeah do it here ok so our sessions and
the summaries of them so session number
one was the introduction but I'll start
with session 2 which was so teaching
equations not now the fundamental idea I
wanted people to learn in this one is to
help students learn equations in big
chunks so doing derivations is generally
antithetical to that because students
will just see the little symbols and
they'll see a ton and ton and ton and
ton of symbols and their chunk size is
much smaller than you so you will
overload their short-term memory and
they won't really be understanding that
we just trying to remember and write as
fast as they can so
so is that visible the orange yeah great
oh yeah good you're a good test all
right ok so so teaching equations you
want to try to chunk the equations
because that gives meaning to this for
the students so there's for example what
is each term me why would you expect
that term to show up in the equation
those are the kinds of things that a
book generally does not do very well and
that's something that you as a teacher
actually have a lot of value to add now
I just learned about a book that does
try to do this which is called a
student's guide to Maxwell's equations
which is does anybody know that book
yeah you know okay so it looks fantastic
I'm I'm like number seven or something
in the queue to get a copy from the M
into MIT libraries which shows that
popular it is but what the way it's
organized first of all it's sold an
immense number of copies for a technical
textbook something like 7,000 or
something like that so it's a sort of a
physics bestseller all right it's not
okay it's not an Agatha Christie novel
but it's really well done and each
chapter talks about one see one of the
equations so so there's for roughly
Maxwell's equations and each there's
four chapters 1 / equation so it's
helping the students chunk just by the
very structure of the books but most
folks don't do that aren't that well
that you know I interesting Lee
constructed not thoughtfully constructed
so it's something that you as a teacher
really should do okay the next one
misconceptions so why why do we spend a
whole session on misconceptions well
it's fundamentally important
misconceptions because if you don't know
where your students are you have no
chance of bringing them to where you
want them to go the example that's
classic that's price started this whole
line of research about misconceptions
was students understanding of force and
motion and basically what you find is
that most people intuitive understanding
of force and motion is f equals MV right
that if you if you have an object you
stop pushing it stops moving force and
velocity are connected if you have a
heavier object you have to push it
harder if you have a lighter object you
push it less so force and mass are
connected so it looks like f equals MV
whereas we would like to teach them f
equals ma Newton's second law force
equals mass times acceleration so
there's a fundamental difference there
and if you don't take account of that
you'll end up producing just wrote
knowledge they'll say okay well whenever
I'm happen to be in business class I'll
use that equals MA and I'll just solve
problems symbolically using that
procedure you've told me but I don't
really believe it or understand it or
use it in my own reasoning so my
intuition is no longer available for
reasoning so you may so this by taking
account of students misconceptions and
helping them come to a intuitive
understanding of how things really work
you're actually making them much smarter
so this is known
so that's knowing how students think so
this is pretty much opposite to
behaviorism and this whole line of
because you're you're saying well I
really want to peer into how people are
reflecting and how their cognition works
so what's going on under the hood and
behavior ISM says well know all you need
to do is look at the behavior if they're
solving problems correctly that's fine
whereas actually you want to know well
why do they solve it that way is because
I really understood it or not did they
just say 6 times 3 is 18 because they
they were told or they memorized it or
was it because they really understood it
in which case they can make a word
problem related to it so noting so
knowing how students think they're
actually part of the cognitive
revolution and you're actually
connecting to students directly than
making them much smarter okay homework
and exam questions okay so constructing
homework and exam questions the main
theme of that was Bloom's taxonomy okay
so this was a hierarchy of goals that
you could have so there's full name is a
taxonomy of educational objectives and
the ones we're talking about if you look
at the full title it's the cognitive
domain there's the cognitive and
affective effective means related to
feelings and emotion this this is the
cognitive domain ones I'm talking about
here so are you asking for just
comprehension are you asking for
students to analyze are you asking them
to synthesize knowledge what is the
level of cognitive activity that you're
asking for and generally you want to mix
levels so you don't want to just make
them push the students off a cliff and
say okay
discuss how the you know the first day
in thermodynamics class discuss how the
second law of thermodynamics applies to
the entropy of the universe you know
that's just too hard you push them way
off the cliff and you've jumped wait
till I bloom taxonomy you also don't
want to just give them pure
comprehension problems do they
understand remember the rule that you're
trying to teach rather you want to mix
them and blues taxonomy gives you a
structured way of seeing what level your
questions are at and making sure you mix
them so that you prepare students with
comprehension questions so that they can
later do evaluation questions mutating
course design so for course design the
big idea is take ideas so you want to
organize your course around some kind of
large ideas and ideally those large
ideas we transfer outside of the course
to and if a whole curriculum is
organized around a few large ideas for
example waves an oscillatory motion you
could also organize a whole bunch of a
physics major around ideas like that or
conservation by giving structure to the
curriculum you turn it away from just a
series of unconnected facts like we gave
this topic that topic that topic that
topic you actually give it form and
organization and then it's much more
likely to be built into long lasting
chunks in the students minds okay so
that's one was a six session was
interactive teaching and the main theme
is that questioning and reflecting lead
to long-lasting learning
so I showed you four different three or
four different time scales in which you
could be interactive when you ask
question is when you ask a question you
wait five seconds or actually some of
you suggested seven which is probably
better it's just harder to do but it's
probably better so you wait a certain
amount of time to allow people to
actually formulate questions so that
promotes interaction on a short scale
you can ask short questions one or two
minutes two or three minutes with a
multiple choice right in the middle of
lecture it gives you feedback so it's
related to the misconceptions one you
know you're learning how students think
just as they answer the questions or you
can do longer kind of or you can on the
same time scale you can ask the feedback
questions from this sheet at the end of
the lecture so that's also promoting a
space for questions and you can actually
see how successful that is there's so
many questions actually we could spend
two more sessions answering all the
questions which I'm glad about because
questioning and reflecting and that's
how people make knowledge their own so
the formal name for that is
constructivism now but what you're doing
is you're helping people construct
knowledge and you can do this on a long
scale like for example for a whole
lecture you can use a question like the
wood blocks which I showed you earlier
you can actually do that for an entire
lecture and actually we just did that
for an entire lecture in my art of
approximation class because the wood
blocks leads to xylophones and I brought
in the xylophone we can talk about how
the pitches of the thick and thin wood
blocks relate to the pitches of shorter
and longer as I lephone slats so there's
lots so rich examples like that the one
doesn't have that many of them but when
you do have them you can actually build
a entire session around them and it
produces all these good things
okay 7 so lecture planning and
performing so for the planning of the
lecture just like for the course the
planning of a course you want to
organize it around some kind of big
ideas some kind of thing that gives its
structure the whole lecture you want
want an objective for example by the end
of the lecture I want students to be
able to explain the origin of the terms
in the navier-stokes equation so then
you would choose your activities in
lecture around this goal but that goal
actually just like the longer scale one
for the whole course gives structure to
the lecture and you know what to put in
and what not to put in and the lecture
planning blank sheets or the templates i
gave you them i posted you can use those
to that end okay and then for that's for
the planning part and for the Performing
and the I would say that the main thing
in performing that people don't normally
think about when they think about
teaching is timing okay so if you want
to create little bits of suspense and
interest which are then you know with
little bits of tension that are then
released and you want to do that on
multiple scales short and long you know
the interactive teaching questions from
here help do that especially if you have
a demonstration because people want to
know hmmm is the would think would lot
going to be higher pitch or is going to
be a lower pitch hmm and you'll find
that when you do things like that the
entire room is dead silent because
people really want to know and the way
you structure the questions can promote
that
by having people vote they've now made a
public commitment which then activates
the cognitive dissonance part of
people's mind they don't they have a by
making a public commitment they've now
made their internal state or more
towards the public state which is all I
want to know what's going on and they
really do want to know what's going on
so timing you can use will get a lot of
timing ideas from the interactive
teaching methods but timing is really
important for performing imagine jokes
where people tell you the punchline
first and then they tell you the rest of
the joke they don't go over too well and
most comics least most successful comics
don't do that but we usually do that
with our teaching okay blackboards and
sloppy and slides for teaching so the
main concepts to think about there are
the chunk size that students have and
how much how many spots they have in
short-term memory okay so with the
blackboard you have many advantages for
free which is that on the blackboard you
don't have to use too many short-term
memory slots you can put the entire
session all on one giant set of black
boards in the front and you can offload
a lot of that work on to something
that's in the visual field and present
for everyone all the time so remember
their chunk size is much smaller than
yours so you might see the entire
lecture is one chunk but obviously they
don't see it that way or they wouldn't
be in the lecture they're the learners
and then when you're doing the slides if
you're going to use slides for teaching
to mitigate some of this problem of not
having enough short-term memory slots
not generally not enough space well you
could try to get four black for slide
projectors or three slide projectors but
it's pretty hard to do and it
sort of triples or queen tuples or non
tuples the time to prepare the slides
because you have to synchronize three
different slide presentations so at
least use assertions at the title and
then visual evidence visual evidence is
much easier to remember and the
assertions help people know what to look
for so they're not spending all their
cycles which they don't have that many
of because the short-term memory has
been filled up they're spending their
cycles trying to understand the visual
evidence okay Andy I posted an example a
set of example slides with the text
source there was a request for the text
or so I posted that as well showing this
method of presentation for the factorial
the logarithm of the factorial okay and
then the last one was political barriers
so maybe that the summary could be one
the comment that was on one of the
sheets was is there any hope all right
and I think well that question is it's
coupled to another question so the main
theme from that is that social and
educational
social educational change are coupled so
if there's no hope for education there's
no hope for society or alternatively if
there's hope for society there's hope
for education and vice versa but the
sort of the main positive lesson from
this is that by improving Society you
improve education and also by improving
education you improve Society so that's
one really good reason to want to be a
teacher and to make teaching a part of
your career as I'm sure many of you are
thinking about doing okay so those are
the short summaries of the nine sessions
what I'd like to do now is give you a
chance to ask any questions you have
well of course have our in see well in
10 minutes at ten ten ten o'clock we'll
take a ten-minute break but before that
I want to start the question session so
the way we'll do that is if everyone
could just look at your index card that
you brought with a question or it done
that to be an index card could be a
sheet of paper and spend one minute
thinking about something that puzzles
you you wonder about you're interested
in you'd like to know more about about
anything related to teaching and check
in with a neighbor or two and then we'll
just start doing questions okay and then
we'll have our break at ten so I'll
leave all these guys up here and i'll
mark here your questions
okay so take take another 10 or 20
seconds to formulate a question or
formulate your thoughts or and we'll
start a good so you're not yet kind of
implicitly throughout the semester we've
kind of been thinking that our audiences
like a college-aged audience so if
you're teaching all the people do
differently think question okay so let
me repeat the question and also they'll
give you a chance to bring in one of the
other comments from the question sheets
which is so the question was I what
about teaching older learners so people
who aren't necessarily hard college-age
so middle-aged people I do you have to
do things differently and now before I
answer that let me say why I repeat the
question so their comment was that it's
a good idea to repeat the question 40
because ocw asks that I repeat the
question so it's because they pick up
the microphone picked up i guess is here
and it picks up me much better than the
audience so it's good for that but it's
also good as the comment or pointed out
is good because it makes it shows the
students to her asking the question that
i actually value their questions because
I'm she's telling everybody look this is
something we should all be thinking
about so it brings the whole class
together around it and it also gives me
time to think about the question
although in this case I didn't actually
use any of the time to think about the
question so let me think about the
question now all right so I'm not sure
it actually gives you that much time it
gives you like one or two seconds but
actually if you want one or two seconds
it's best to just sort of just be sit
there still and think for one or two
seconds so that's what I'm going to do
now
okay so now I waited actually four
seconds is to show that it's possible to
do that so difficult because it so there
is there are some things that are
different in it it I say one of the main
differences is the not just the
misconceptions but the conceptions of
learning that people have so for example
you might be teaching people who just
failed out of math in school never did
math again and now you want to help them
learn math or you want to help them
learn reading and they always thought of
themselves as terrible readers so now
they've been so they've imbibed the
lesson of the blue eyes brown eyes
experiment which is that they're bad at
this there you know for whatever reason
it's their fault you know and we're very
good at that right we're very good at
passing blame so why didn't people learn
physics oh well physics is a very hard
subject not that we teach it terribly
it's a very bad heart subject so
basically we're saying blame the victim
and I was very convenient but after a
while of that the victim actually starts
to get Stockholm Syndrome so you know
they start to identify with their
captors and they agree yes because it's
a really hard subject I never had a head
for physics so as an experiment for that
next time you go to a party ask people
what you do I mean obviously not a party
of other graduate students in science
and engineering because they wouldn't
work in this that test wouldn't work
here but just for example like sue my
officemate he used to live in when I was
a graduate student used to live in
Hollywood West Hall in Hollywood itself
so he used to go to party and his
roommate was a script rewriter so his
script rewrite his roommate would
actually scripts that were considered
too bad even to make movies out of but
they really thought they should make a
movie out of it because they thought
they could make a lot of money if they
just rewrote the script to bits is sort
of like degrade scripts that needed to
be who made c-grade his roommate rewrote
them so he had a lot of Hollywood
connections so they had a lot of party
and he had a lot of parties with people
who weren't from Caltech which was good
so go to a party like that and ask and
when people say oh what do you do say oh
I'm a chem
tree guy just I I teach physics all
right I'm a TA for this class or I'm
working on a PhD and you know
mathematics and just watch how fast
people run right they are you know so if
they're more polite the either they if
they're not very polite they'll say oh
you do right right but if they're not as
polite if they're more polite they'll
actually say oh that was how I was was
terrible with that that was never my
thing ok so now and this is so prevalent
so now what do you have to do in that
case well you have to then so that's
their misconception and so number three
up there you really take account of that
that their way of thinking about math
and phys the way that it was taught to
them completely did not work and it just
produced fear and phobia so now would
you have to do is you have to go around
that and so one of the ways actually
Brian butterworth who's actually studies
this he's a professor of neurophysiology
in London I and I mentioned his book a
couple times i think is called the
mathematical brain or what counts
depending on whether it's the english or
american title so math phobia is a lot
caused by people having a fear that
there's only one way to get the right
answer right so they think they're
they're walking across a tightrope and
if you make one misstep when you fall
into the abyss right and so of course if
you have that conception of mathematical
reasoning and problem-solving you're
going to have a lot of fear all right so
what you have to do is you have to show
people know actually draw it over here
so if this was their model
then if that's the one way way to get to
the solution actually you want to show
them not that but and show them even
dead ends you know not every method of
solution will work out so I might just
end up there and some I end up there
some connect to other methods and get to
a solution and even maybe that's one
solution but maybe there's two so you
want to show them that there's robust
path across the river let's say you're
not trying to for example jump Niagara
Falls where one misstep and down you go
so that's a way of reducing the math
phobia now that's a particular example
but that's an example of how you have to
think slightly differently for the adult
learner the reason is that they've had
longer time to internalize the
misconception the high school student
they haven't necessary for example they
haven't necessarily formed their own
view of themself and it's less true in
college level that people are starting
to form their view of self more and more
but it's still changeable especially in
America and that's one really excellent
part the American University system so
you may not realize it if you come from
America but in almost every other
country in the world when you go to
university that's you pick your subject
and that's what you do for the rest of
the university time I so England for
example it's even before that if you
want to do physics at Cambridge you had
to have done for the last two years of
high school basically everyone into
physics at Cambridge did physics math
chemistry and further maths further
maths so I should say so further maths
are just more maths basically like DC
CAF de calculus so they did for the last
four year two years of school only math
and physics and chemistry courses and
then they go on to university and they
do just physics and Cambridge had a
radical innovation on that which was
that in the first year you didn't do
just physics you did
physics math chemistry and maybe a
fourth subject so that was considered
really you know very progressive I it
was compared to the rest of the
educational system so in Europe in
general we don't have there isn't that
freedom so in America you still have it
so the students and colleges are still
going to be quite different from the
people who basically fix their view of
themself as bad at math or bad at
whatever and that's one of the things
that you change when you're thinking
about adult learners okay I'll take one
question fruit back there and then we'll
have our break yeah Ben is at the
experiment mkay so what happened to the
Ben is at experiment in New Hampshire so
this was in the Venice Lewis benefit was
superintendent of schools in Manchester
New Hampshire from 1924 to 1938 and so
what happened you know if it was so
great where is it now so I might have
mentioned that i actually went and did
research on what happened to it and i
went to the manchester new hampshire
school board and just spent a whole day
in their archives reading all the
minutes of all the school board
discussions about it and all the votes
about Ben is it and whether to reappoint
him a superintendent or what to do about
the curriculum and basically what
happened was two things so first of all
there was extensive studies done showing
that the curriculum was very successful
so one study was by
so Etta Berman she was a teacher in
Manchester yeah in that program and then
she did her master's in education I'm
pretty sure at Boston University yes I'm
sure it is because you can find her
thesis in the Boston University Library
so she did her her education thesis was
an assessment of how the students did in
that experimental program versus the
regular program and the students in the
experiment program were just much better
I was just totally clear so now what
happened well what happened partly was
that I think it's a lot of it is what
Alfie Kohn article about not for my kid
how privileged parents undermined school
reform so there was a huge opposition
from the privileged parents and so I
interviewed some of the people who had
those privileged parents who had taken
that curriculum 50 or 60 years ago and
one of them was later mayor of
Manchester and he said his parents just
hated the curriculum so generally the
people whose parents were foreign for
example French Quebecois who'd come to
New Hampshire and to work in the mills
the non-english speakers the lower
middle class it was okay it was fine and
the ones I talked to from that
background love the curriculum and then
the few really hated it we're actually
socially quite powerful and they came
from the predominantly english-speaking
families and they hated that he wasn't
for example giving homework because he
said you know if you have eight hours of
school what more homework do you need
which i think is actually true if you
can't teach people in eight hours a day
I mean that's ridiculous it's 40 hours a
week hey so you know why are you giving
them still more homework all right so he
didn't have homework he had them
actually learned in school which is one
of the benefits of interactive teaching
if your lecture is no longer dictation
you're actually learning you don't have
to do a lot of stuff out of school so
there was opposition there so and what
happened was the votes in the school
board when something like this so this
is T this is 1938 1924 and this is the
votes in favor minus against they went
roughly like this so the school board I
think had about it had about I think I
had 15 people on it or 14 people at
dependent sometimes one person wasn't on
the school board so the first votes were
something like 13 to one so in other
words plus 12 and then over here 1924
when he was first appointed and then the
votes went like this and I started going
down like that and by 1938 so there was
votes taken every three or four years or
two years to whether to renew the
appointment because I was at the term
and by here this was the vote was six to
six right here yeah that's right it was
626 of 1937 and then what happened in
1938 was they didn't vote to not take
him on but what they did is they voted
to use a standard textbook so they voted
to use a standard textbook in the
curriculum and then the standard
textbook was then the curriculum was
then declared income incompatible with
the standard text books of course the
standard textbook was pretty terrible
well I don't know the textbook
personally but I'm sure given the state
of standard text books then and now so
and it certainly wasn't the progressive
kind of understand the algorithms
approach that Ben is at had so then the
textbook was instituted and the
curriculums basic killed off like that
so then Ben is at left for a
professorship of education at Dartmouth
and then they've after Ben azat left so
this is venison Ben is that left the new
superintendent put in a basically drill
and kill curriculum with lots of testing
and
sort of a standard now there's no child
left behind 60 years before send 70
years before its time okay but the
curriculum was very successful and it is
basically killed off by opposition from
wealthy parents and to be fair from
venez venez it didn't help his case so a
couple of the students told me that
actually when the students wouldn't
answer things in class he would
sometimes make fun of them now that's
terrible I mean it's terrible just on
moral grounds but also it's terrible
political strategy because now the
parents are going to go I mean the kids
will tell their parents and if the
parents needed a me ammunition at all
there they have it so Bennett Bennett I
was just arming the enemy too yeah it
did good question okay well yes they're
a good question so is there a comparable
force in college education to Paris with
privilege yeah and unfortunately it's
one's colleagues on the faculty the
reason is because they were the ones who
did well by the old system and so now a
change that a change is likely to be
misinterpreted or maybe rightly
interpreted as well this isn't for the
benefit of the top 5% so we can't do it
I so for example interactive teaching is
often criticized as well that's really
useful for the people who aren't
learning anything but the top 5% just
slow them down so it can possibly do it
so their wars about interactive teaching
turn on a lot of that question and that
is a very similar force because people
are saying well it's those people who
are just like me because they're the
ones who are going to become future
faculty and those ones aren't going to
be benefited by the system now I think
empirically that's not true I think the
they'll actually are benefited as well
and then as I found that too it wasn't
that some people get worse
all doing better but it's that the
intensity of the response that you get
to things sometimes in that vein shows
that it's an underlying social force and
not just purely a cognitive reason is
that a and what you are thinking about
okay so 1008 so 1018 we'll start again
with more questions ok so I know I know
there are several more questions because
i already have two in the queue go ahead
and then lourdes yeah question okay what
do you I don't know no sorry no no no
the question was what do you do when
you're confronted with a question that
you don't know the answer to my answer
was I have no idea I know I know I
there's good answers to that question
and hopefully i'll give you one of them
alright so the i would say the number
one thing is not not the [ __ ] that
that can only end at best it won't end
in disaster but it can end in disaster
so the first thing so if you don't know
the answer to it but you have to think
what's going to get triggered in you so
if it's something for example really
related to the material you're more
likely to get triggered and thank excuse
me oh I should have known the answer to
that I must be a lousy teacher how will
they ever respect me again so if you
remember the discussion we had last time
about in political barriers about the
three levels of which conversations are
carried on so this was from difficult
conversations there's the factual level
the emotional level in the meaning level
so the fact level is that someone's just
asked you a question when you don't know
the answer right away the emotional
reaction an emotional transmission is oh
my god I feel worried and nervous and
then the meaning level is Oh what does
that mean for me oh it means
that I'm a bad teacher they found me out
right I'm really not supposed to be here
right right and so that the same thing
happens with students when you ask them
a question they don't know so you want
to create structures where that meaning
that bad meaning isn't trigger so you
want to just pause first of all the
reason is if you don't pause then you're
more likely to act out based on the
emotion so I've seen this happen several
times now when I was a graduate student
which is that whether the so this is
sometimes when the person didn't know
but in general when they were somehow
challenged by the question so either way
whether it's because you don't know the
answer or because the students tone has
some kind of cheekiness to it and you
feel a bit of insolence and you think
I'm the teacher got in it how dare you
talk to me like that right so on so that
emotional reaction whether it's or that
that challenge that worried that anxiety
about your authority will produce a bad
response in general okay so if you just
right away respond you're likely to do
bad things and this is the thing I've
seen happen a few times is where you put
the student down you compete with the
student you say things like well how
could you not know that ready to dismiss
the question so if you pause for just
one or two seconds even an instant after
you practice it just the pausing to
realize oh wait a minute I just had an
emotional reaction happen I felt it in
my body I got bit sweaty my palms
sweated whatever it may be that your
particular reaction is if I feel it
often in my face my face gets warm if
you remember way back when we were doing
the was it the wood blocks or the cones
no it was the cones I was dropping the
cones and there was a question when it
was time for Question discussion one
person said oh the answer is block and
I've seen you do it before and I just
remember just feeling flushed and I was
like okay this is not the time to answer
that question so it's the same thing so
that's more lesson number one is to
pause and then you could think and
regroup and have a reflective response
the reflective response maybe oh you
know that's a really interesting
question
I'd never thought about that but I'm
going to think about that tonight and
I'll tell you the next time that's
perfectly fine another one is you can
try to figure out the answer together
you say well i'm not sure but let's see
if we can figure out the answer in the
next minute or two if not i'll work on
it in the evening or we're kind of
tomorrow and tell you and then you can
try it together and they have the
students have the advantage of seeing
how you would reason about a question
and it helps if you do that
intentionally because there's a sort of
general rule of thumb is which is that
one's facility with equations declines
okay with distance to the blackboard so
the closer to the blackboard the lower
the facility of equation so if you're
just leap to the blackboard and start
writing you're likely to feel too
nervous and actually just mess it up
just because of that so if you say okay
well let's actually think about doing
this together think about what you might
do and think about some approaches then
go to the blackboard maybe start working
and you know and you have your out if it
doesn't work in too many say okay look
it's a good question i'll tell you we
need to think about this some more and
i'll do that i'll come back to you does
that help answer your question
absolutely somebody would point out a
different way of doing something and you
not really right so what if somebody
produces yeah if you're going to do
interactive teaching you're going to
have lots of discussions so people think
Oh interactive teaching needs you just
let the students do everything you just
kick back no actually it's actually much
harder because you have to it's your now
you've changed it back from basically
playing a pre-recorded tape which is
what a lot of lecturing is you just get
out and read the book that's what a lot
of my lecturers did too it's now a stage
performance I stays performance in the
old days of Elizabethan theatre where
the audience interacted with the stage
so that's much harder you have to really
know quote you have to quote know your
lines not that you're going to say the
same lines no matter what you have to
really feel the lines you have to really
understand the field so it is harder and
you're going to be producing lots of
discussions and at a place like MIT the
students who are very curious and
they're going to think oh well what
about this well that's fine so you want
to use sort of Aikido so if someone
suggests something you hadn't thought of
don't dismiss it you say oh I and
thought of that that's a really good
suggestion which is usually maybe i'll
use that next year when i teach the
course thank you so if you just think
about the students as your allies then
your reaction that you'll intrinsically
produce will be much less
confrontational and much less worried
okay so i'll give you one example of she
where i was eating very very nervous and
what I did so this was I was lecturing
thermodynamics and there were 200
students and I was doing the Carnot
cycle so this was the last lecture so we
were doing the Carnot cycle and I drew
it up on the board and you know i'd
encourage questions throughout the whole
lecturer throughout the whole lecture
course so of course someone raised their
hand said oh excuse me i think that this
box should be is not right they didn't
know what was wrong with i said over
that box isn't right so I looked at it
I thought oh my god they're right so
I've now I've just drawn rubbish on the
board in front of 200 people and I had a
bunch of my colleagues that day who
happened to decide that was a day to
come visit my lecture alright so I think
that was probably why I was a bit
nervous to begin with and then and that
probably contributed to me writing down
the wrong diagram so I realized I needed
some time to actually think so I just
said you know you're right let me just
think and I just turned my back and for
a whole minute and I sorted out what was
wrong and then everything was buying
after that but I still remember that I
still remember the feeling in my body
just that sinking feeling of oh my god
disaster has happened right I've just
been exposed no really I should have
been one of the students in the class so
pausing is immensely valuable ludus yeah
ok right so when you often when you want
to do something more interactive in your
teaching the counter arguments are well
you're just you're going to harm the top
5% well one counter argument so first of
all it doesn't often help to counter
argue cognitive reasons if there's an
emotional underpinning so generally I
try to step aside from those arguments
because they unless the people have a
sense of humor I find if the people have
a sense of humor then you can actually
say you can present things in a humorous
way that challenge their view and
they've they can take it on board but if
they don't have a sense of humor or you
don't have a good way of presenting it
that way I find it's just wiser to step
aside and see if you can find some way
around it maybe try half of what you
wanted to do or say well yeah you know I
worry about that to a bit so let's leave
the main course alone that way let's try
an experiment see how it goes maybe we
can agree on some questions that all the
students should be able to do to try to
make it cooperative so that's one thing
but if you can if you do want to sort of
go directly into cognitive discussions
and reasons one is
and this has scope for making humor
obvious that what's a top student I mean
the top students the top quote five
percent or the top 5% by the current
system of testing and homeworks so
they're often the top 5% in
regurgitating can't formulas or by the
time they get higher and higher and more
selections happen they're good at
pattern matching in solving problems
they don't even understand I mean
certainly the final exam in Cambridge
that people took in their final year if
I just sat down I would not have passed
it in the physics department and so
there were students who did really
really well on it but I'm sure I
understood more physics in them and it's
because if you train for those kind of
questions even he don't really
understand what you're doing I you can
actually answer them so now the top five
percent of that well is that so valuable
to preserve maybe actually we should
change the rules of the game so now if
you just say it directly as I've said it
then you'll trigger the meaning of what
because a lot of the times tho those
five percent became that people you're
talking to so you have to do it maybe do
it slightly differently and say look
what is the thing you're most concerned
about about the students not knowing
whether the top five percent or not and
a lot of times people they'll just give
you a big long list they'll say oh on
their own before you even say they'll
say oh they can never use anything
outside of the class so though people
will just drive over I concede that not
even can see they'll say yeah it's so
terrible and people will talk about this
all the time say look we all agree that
okay well let's see is there a way that
we can make people really good at that
because even the top 5% I find or not
like that so now you've opened a door
and you can have a shared discussion
based on something like that okay so
that's how you can reach sort of the
eighty percent who are not sure but are
willing to listen yeah
of these surveys they have an MIT by H
the students evaluate the professors and
teachers and also oh good I'm glad you
said that for several reasons so one of
the other reasons is that this course
has 12 so it's but so the way that I'll
put it on the course website just after
class so all to its 595 is one of the
course numbers but it's also six-point
92 or something so all course six
classes have an online evaluation system
so for everybody we're doing it that way
so everybody who is registered for the
class is listed as a possible survey
filler router so I encourage everyone to
i'll put the link on the website just
click on the link and if you have your
MIT certificates installed it'll just
take you to the online survey so I think
this surveys are very useful now the
numbers the numbers are sort of a
ballpark well what were things working
or not but I think the most useful part
of the surveys is the comments people
make so again I encourage you to make
comments in the comment boxes wherever
they are for example there's one that
says what would you suggest for people
next year so part of that I'm going to
learn by reading these so I'll crib good
ideas from how you would do this course
from your homeworks but the survey will
how she helped with that so I think the
surveys are really useful if used
properly I don't think they're very
useful for saying okay you get tenure
you don't get tenure because the numbers
and people just use the numbers for that
I don't think the numbers are super
reliable I mean seven is probably
significant better than four or five but
there are a lot of ways to get six and a
half and set say six or five how did
that happen well you want to really look
into the course and see that and the
course survey doesn't really address
that super well but the comments give
you space if you really listen closely
to understand it so I think they're
quite useful but what I'd really like to
see
is because those are surveys right after
the class and you know my goal what I've
been trying to stress this whole time is
how can you construct teaching for a
long lasting learning you know
questioning and reflecting ideally the
long-lasting learning well if it really
lasts long people should remember
something a year later so I think
actually the policy should be changed to
you know do feedback sheets at the end
of each lecture so you get the quick
feedback you need as the lecture and
then by the end of this course you have
a lot of feedback and you can really
improve things next time and then do the
survey a year after the course is
finished and if people don't remember
anything from the course right away
that's a pretty important piece of
feedback so I fear though that the
results from that kind of survey who it
would be quite distressing because
people would ask things like well which
of the ideas from the course do you use
and when people do some people have done
surveys like that in physics majors so
the surveys of physics majors in the job
whether they're a research or an
industry or finance well before that
ended what are you used from your
physics degree and very very rarely do
you find people saying if you just
average across all the jobs Maxwell's
equations it's not on the list is very
low on the list it's things like general
problem-solving quantitative skills
working in groups now it's not initially
true that therefore we should just dump
all our classes and teach me a lot of
working groups that's not what I'm
saying but it's useful to know what
people are doing with the things you
teach them so that you can take that
into account so that would be my ideal
surveys one year five years ten years
later there are a few of those at MIT
alumni surveys Becky I know has done a
few of them okay other questions this
slow say you're a new teacher you can of
course design it and really think about
how you want to do it a lot of numbers
etc and your find out yeah 23 years good
question yeah so so the question is you
know you make a new course two or three
years you refined it after five years
doesn't become boring my guess is
probably yeah unless you keep changing
it so I've taught part of approximation
for almost nine years now and every
three years I could for four years I
completely figure out a new way of doing
it and now it's finally converging I
would say now I finally you know realize
oh the main thing because I didn't know
this when i first started because i was
a new teacher so to organize it around
large ideas main themes transferable
technique so i finally converge to that
and now i'm changing the examples and so
there i would say the / debate is
probably converging but i could probably
keep doing that for another three or
four years but if you just do it so we
were fighting for two or three years and
then just keep doing it I would say yeah
after another couple years it's not
necessarily that it'll get boring
because when you teach this way the
teaching always stays interesting but
it's that you find yourself maybe just
thinking about other courses and I
already have a sign that that's
happening because i'm now thinking home
you know I'd like to make a physics of
music class you know and they may be
related to the other class because we
just did the wood blocks and the
xylophone in my approximation class I'm
thinking oh you know a whole class and
the physics of music would be really a
lot of fun to make may organize it
around demonstrations and you could
bring in the physics as needed for the
demonstration you choose all the
demonstrations so that all the main
physical ideas in acoustics and
electromagnetism mechanics and sound and
are all combined oh that would be a
really nice design problem so maybe I'm
converging with the art of approximation
one after nine years so it depends how
often you keep changing things but yeah
and that's okay because you'll find that
that's the natural life cycle so
example if you're a faculty member say
in almost any university in the country
every after six years you get a
sabbatical so in the sabbatical you'd be
very well advised I mean you could teach
if you want to be very well advised to
not show up on any committees not teach
and generally you're pretty much
required not to and then just leave
because otherwise you'll be dealing with
all the normal run-of-the-mill things
you won't be able to have a block of
time to really think so if you've
developed this course and this your
course after five or six years it's
automatically going to have to be given
to somebody else and that's fine because
that's around the time that you'll be
thinking about other stuff and this
sabbatical is a time to reorient
yourself towards other stuff so looking
ahead towards that what you want to do
is write up what you do so the first
year it's pretty hard you're just barely
scrambling you're trying to breathe like
having four children as having
quadruplets well maybe I don't know I
haven't had that happening but I is the
first year you do of course a brand-new
course especially on three days a week
one it's pretty hard so i can tell you
you know this is two hours a week but
it's the first time i've taught this
course so it's a lot of work I and that
will be true so the first year yeah you
just want to survive the second year you
start to figure out what to do what to
write and just start writing stuff up
bit by bit you know lecture notes
problem sets that are you know typeset
things that other people can reuse
pretty easily so then when the course is
handed off to somebody else they can
continue that and refine it based on
what you've done and everything you did
doesn't just vanish yeah
you mentioned in classes you really a
lot of teaching and carne ideas then put
some of the mechanistic did the grunge
so yeah okay so the question is so I
like to use lecture time for the larger
ideas for the concepts for the for the
chunks I said for example in the
teaching equation one and leave the
derivations and detailed manipulations
the mechanics of stuff the mecha grunge
let's say for the textbook do I have any
suggestions for how to choose a good
textbook well it becomes less it is
important to choose a good textbook but
it becomes less important if the
classroom is focusing on concepts and
chunks because that's the differentiator
generally between the good and the bad
textbooks is that the good textbooks do
more of that so if you're focusing on
that in the classroom then you have more
freedom not freedom to use bad textbooks
but the bad textbooks don't do you as
much harm because the students don't
need so much out of the textbook they
need to basically have a place where the
derivations are correct then that's an
important part and it has the
derivations you need sure so right away
you can relax about choosing the
textbook slightly but how do you find
good ones actually now I look at the
reviews online and see what students say
about them so I do a web search for
books and I see what books people are
using what people are commenting on and
look at on the online bookstores the
various reviews of the books that helps
a lot and then nowadays often people put
the first chapter and the table of
contents online the publishers do and
ideally they would put the whole book
online some are doing that too so how to
look at that from the table of contents
you can really tell a lot about a
textbook you say whom is this organized
right I just have the right philosophy
that I'm looking for so look look right
away at the preface where the author
talks about why this book and
have no good reason for why this book
it's probably not the book for you
sometimes you don't have a choice about
the book people just say well this is
the book that we always use or this the
first time you've taught the course for
example you're hired in July you're
hired say in March you start your job in
July and in August they come to you and
say oh yeah by the way professor blahs
on sabbatical teaching X you're up the
course book is already there so you
can't do much about that so sometimes
you don't have freedom but then when you
do want to do it so look at the preface
and the online reviews are quite helpful
but don't worry as much if your
classroom is interactive that mitigates
a lot of textbook problems I wonder
actually if there is some semi your
analysis of what is more effective
because I mean I see then I mean in
general i guess it goes that if you have
a variety then you have no higher than
the sea that will be laid back but the
advantage of like have you taken only
campus your math and physics in your
honor is it then you know you know a lot
about that right and they're also like
all right do you know who i have never
seen proof that math skills in the US
and good people come from outside and
and also you know we were talking about
this you know doing a class physics of
music yeah and then you know I wondering
well you know every get an undergrad you
know to that class is there thinking you
know like a physics hard for Matt glad I
would you have taken you know like you
know this class will give you the tools
to work rather than you know so glad I
will enjoy but like that I rather have
you thinking you know later on at the
end of your grasp so okay so let me
unpack those so there were several
questions in there so first is there a
difference between the are there any
studies on the difference between the
results produced by the European say
educational system versus the american
or the European where people just do
their one subject to first order where
the American one where you take courses
across many different subjects I'm not
sure about that but also though the
notion of effectiveness is not clear so
the goal what's the goal so that the
American one I think that historical
reasons why it's different is that
education in America early on back in
colonial times and just post colonial
times or you know their early 1800s was
seen as a democratic thing the idea was
that this is a democracy and all the
citizens are expected to participate in
that and so okay they had a narrow
definition of citizens just white males
but within that definition the idea was
that everybody
had to participate or is going to
participate so for that to that in they
needed a broad education they couldn't
just specialize in one thing because
they would be too narrow to actually
help cover in society because society is
multi farias and multidisciplinary
intrinsically whereas in Europe that
idea of democracy came hundreds of years
later if at all you know maybe at the
end of World War one so the European
educational system was much more trained
for producing people in a much more
oriented towards producing people who
would fit into a particular slot in
society all right so now if you want to
measure how effective each was at its
historical goals I think that's a fair
question to measure how effective each
is at producing people who are trained
for a particular spot in society I don't
think that's a very useful analysis
because the historical origins of the
two systems are different it's much more
fruitful I would say to think about the
goals which goals do we agree with no k
can we get the benefits of the American
goal with some of the benefits of the
specialization in Europe and I think at
places like MIT you do do that I mean
the students have come out of MIT they
have a broader education than the
students who come out of European
universities and they actually know a
lot now I would like it to be much more
conceptual and long-lasting but that's
true of the European ones too so I would
take the question back from just
studying the end results to think
carefully as a society about the
purposes now about the physics of music
I would say actually I can imagine
teaching an intro physics course that's
physics of music where they would get
students would learn all the fundamental
ideas of say first semester physics but
through the physics of music and I don't
think it would be so they wouldn't be
deprived of the essential knowledge of
physics they would actually be
contextualized so they might actually
learn it for a longer lasting it might
have a longer lasting value okay what
talk about emotional barriers and I
think one of the big ones that have seen
especially in students at MIT through TA
or district hearing people talk is I
don't belong here I must have gotten
here by accident yeah and I can so many
people say that to themselves at one
time or them all times while they're
here that what it can't possibly be true
because everybody is saying it because I
don't think anything you do in your
teaching if they have that barrier up I
don't think there's there's much to do
to sort of combat that so how do you get
through that concert no matter how clear
your teaching is if they're if they're
worried that they're not going to get it
yeah if they're in the math phobic mode
or phobic mower so this is a really
interesting question so that the comment
was that a lot of people at MIT lot of
students one of the emotional barriers
they have is they feel I would call that
a meaning barrier if you if you let me
rephrase it in the three levels of
conversation so their motion is that
they're very tense and anxious and the
meaning is that they're feeling they
when something doesn't go right for them
they get something wrong on a problem
set or in class they feel like that's
they think that that's exposing how they
really don't belong here and that
creates a lot of anxiety and tension and
misery so in Caltech that was a saying
that oh yeah caltex a terrible place for
the bottom half of the 99th percentile
you know it captures that pretty well
like all these people who all the
undergrads went to Caltech right they
were probably valid torian's in their
high school and two Sigma's above and
like doing science fair projects than
everybody else around them and now they
come to Caltech and they feel terrible
like what are we doing that produces
that you know it's crazy so how can your
teaching can you take account of that
you know so that i would say it also
relates partly to the misconceptions you
know they have this misconception or
this conception about themselves and
what can you do well it's wit phobias
are very difficult you have to work
around them so one thing is you you
don't want to trigger them all right so
every time you trigger them you
reinforce them because it made that
I so than any neurobiology people in
here forget pcs ok well the fundamental
rule of neurobiology of brain neurons so
this is of course i teach the art of
approximation so forgive me for
approximating whole brain with one
sentence is neurons that fire together
wire together ok so if is a wiring
together that means they they activate
they increase their coupling and so
increasing their so when they fire
together so for example they you create
a classroom environment or something
happen in the classroom that they get
something wrong and now there's that
five that is still wired somewhat to the
bad feeling and there are thoughts of oh
my god I don't belong here so now you've
reinforced that they're going to wire
together more reinforces that pathway so
what you have to do is find a way to
actually prevent those guys from lying
together one thing is create an
environment where whenever people get
things wrong it's actually great right
so oh that wasn't right great now think
how much you're going to learn or when
you get things wrong you want to model
that to you say oh you're right oh
thanks you I've learned something from
that you know so try not to be defensive
because that will help because if you're
defensive then that triggers them wiring
that that wiring in them and that firing
together builds up the wine killer so
creating a classroom environment where
feeling bad and competing against other
people isn't the goal is one way to
minimize it so minimizing the importance
of like defined distinctions on homework
did I get a 95 oh that person's getting
a 95 I only got it 90 so that's one
reason MIT was pass/fail in the intro
for a whole year originally was
pass/fail and that was to mitigate the
pressure that students were coming in
feeling like oh my god now I don't
belong here listen look we don't care
about your grades in the first year
you're really here to adjust the
university the different way of learning
and now who was actually done in a way
that somehow the competition is partly
the students reinforcing the culture the
upperclassmen as well if you could
actually try to mitigate that you have
you go a long way
towards mitigating me wiring together
but you can do it in your own classroom
too but de-emphasizing the things that
trigger that and so when you call on
people I so for example for that reason
to MIT I almost never what's called cold
calling if you ever seen that old movie
the paper chase so the paper chase is
about the what's called the where we
could call today the terroristic
Socratic method so the law schools all
uses Socratic method where you ask
people they read a case and you ask them
about things things about it ok mr.
Jones what do you think what were the
findings of law well mr. Smith or mrs.
Darkwell off what do you think about
that do you agree with that or is that
pure rubbish so people will just put on
the spot repeatedly and they just
produce terror in the students and that
was considered part of the hazing ritual
basically so at MIT I just don't do that
at all because i think it just triggers
that and i'd rather just create a
structure whereby students feel ready to
participate by presenting the
interactive teaching giving them time to
think to each other and then say
something so you can do stuff and it's
hard it's an important problem yeah sure
most of my life I'm like cuz I had a
customer in my undergrad who actually
came in and said Jim group of us knew
what it was and she said how many of you
felt like basically for your posture and
it just it's just a matter of time and
discovers you I don't like all Hanson
said a one we know it wasn't alone one
night major but fourth major award the
field but I saw to it that way so it is
normal kinda like I best like run in my
head even has a family and like to know
that not everyone yeah actually worth
saying yes it's a really good point so
the point was that it's worth while
making it explicit for the students and
really naming the feeling that they're
going through like look you may be
feeling really terrible and feeling like
you're an imposter well let it be known
that I felt the same way to for a long
time and describe it to them and talk to
them about why they may be feeling that
say look we have a competitive this is
they there's a culture of competition in
the society in the university and it's
actually harmful for your learning and
share share with them some readings
about that help them see that yeah this
is something that gonna have to struggle
with but there's help to do that and
they're not alone in that so yeah
definitely be explicit about things like
that okay I think one more question yeah
good question do I think contextualizing
the course of the way to fight that I
think it is because when the course is
not contextualized it generally tends to
be really abstractly focused and the the
interest and the orientation towards
doing things first abstractly is very
rare I don't have it and I've gone
really far in math and physics my
officemate had it and graduate school he
was the only person I've ever met who
would rather have a proof than a picture
all right and now he's a professor at
Caltech and he's also doing well but
it's pretty rare so by contextualizing
the course for almost everybody hecky I
would say even for my friend and office
mate you're actually connecting to a
much larger part of their mind in their
experience so you're actually making
people much more intelligent and much
more equal in that way so that's one
reason I would actually like to teach
the fees that physics a music class
interesting yeah so somehow gets around
the phobia you might have pardoned
interesting so that wasn't so I was
there 10 years ago and that wasn't true
then so clearly they've done so the
comment was at a caltech now the
required classes all have a contextual
version as well I they and I think
that's a great idea it's also from your
point of view it's really fun as a
future teacher because you get to think
of all the interesting context in which
your field is useful ready connects you
back to the reason you did the field
originally can that's good to remember
because you'll be going along and you'll
be absorbed in your research trying to
get tenure or whatever it may be and you
may free they'll be all these layers are
created on top and you'll forget why you
came into the field to begin with and if
you can capture that feeling actually if
you can connect to that feeling in you
then you'll actually be able to transmit
that feeling to your students and they
all have it as well and you'll actually
be doing good for the field good for you
and good for your students so with that
I'll wish you lots of success in your
teaching I hope that the principles and
examples that we've done throughout the
term you find useful at least in one way
and I look forward to hearing from you
later how you use will not use or any
suggestions that you may have so good
luck